a bunch of girls  [Applause]  give it up again Java raster  come on granite columns garden  [Applause]  comes  [Applause]  this is after a game this is after a  gang hit last night its first ever sec  do it at this again oh good this is our  impressive man oh my goodness you know  we say in the TV business we'll fix that  in post  bradycardic he'll get a chance at one  [Music]  [Applause]  the job  they want give the people what they want  so here we go here we go but what they  want when we see it next year for real  here he goes  back-to-back Lahey go ahead he in with a  hat see we wouldn't have to see  [Applause]  - John give the job for Watson come on  give the job already  I know you back home I know come on  get your phones up  [Applause]  bunch of non puddin Granta Clark out in  slow he said wait for this  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]